what's going on guys today we're coming
to you from valencia california where we
were invited to take a look at a huge
lot of screen use star trek crops that
are going up for auction real soon
so let's boldly go where no man has gone
before
I'm standing here with Alec Peters he is
the founder of prop works and they've
got a big event coming up Alec I want
you to tell me what everything behind us
is in these cases for what you're gonna
do with it so we are holding the first
of three Star Trek prop and costume
options this is screen-used props and
costumes from Star Trek there's actual
Shatner DNA on some of this stuff some
of this stuff I'm sure there's some
shattered DNA he had an issue we're
gonna open this cam oh it's not even
locked so I could have been shoplifting
the entire time well we have cameras
everywhere Oh gotcha
so this is one of the best items in the
auction and this is an original
next-generation tricorder what's special
about this is this has the medical
scanner in the top so this is a medical
tricorder hi mom I know it's snowy there
she's in New Jersey Oh what is it Oh
65 yeah this is a Frankie pear that
quark used in Star Trek Wow
yeah and then we have others I go
through here's a Cardassian and a
Kardashian pad my dad oh this is a
Bajoran pad I'm married to Kanye West
they still married I thought yeah no
they're totally still married they have
a baby North West really geez get your
head out of Star Trek you know Kanye
West and me people can Kardashian at a
baby Oh what's this that is a crew pass
from Star Trek oh this is to get on the
lot how much would this go for that's
such an extreme might be $25 it's really
who would pay $25 for the Salish
Rickey's Trekkies for this it's a crew
badge that stuff oh all right so some
people okay this is the gun that Soren
used to kill Kirk in Star Trek next
generations whoa yeah so that is
literally the gun day okay I'm going to
leave here with this item and you can't
stop me so how much
you think something like this will go
for right that will go for somewhere
between three and four thousand dollars
holy moly yeah really yeah I'll give you
five bucks for it right now
no oh here's another great item this is
a Klingon knife so this is like this is
like Worf looks like Worf territory Yeah
right like you saw in Star Trek 3 when
they killed Kirk's son with that oh yeah
that was a Ronald working one out now
this is what we call stud knives so this
knife will be the one that flies out the
window right exactly so there you go so
you know we could hit each other and
tututututu it I'm sorry I couldn't
remember the Star Trek music so just
started humming some West Side Story
well that's okay yeah sharks on the Jets
oh I love this these right here are from
an episode called mr. Sulu barbecue I
don't think so
no no and here for you is the USS
Enterprise dedication plaque I put this
in my file a bring a young lady home is
this gonna help seal the deal depends if
she's a Star Trek fan or not so the
answer's no okay
and then next we've got these are three
different ship models and you see
they're all beat up and destroyed they
were made for the various ship graveyard
scenes like the Battle of Wolf 359 how
much is this thing on a fetch probably
uh my guess is $3,000 it's always 3,000
what a number people like bid yeah
people feel really comfortable at $3,000
you go to four it starts getting
expensive a 38 bucks yeah it's not going
to work and then of course this is what
every Star Trek fan knows and loves Oh a
cat toy yes these are real actual
tribbles or tribbles that were used in
Star Trek Deep Space nine this is a
pretty good deal for the tribbles
because you buy one and you get like
then a million tribbles because they
multiply we don't guarantee that here is
the first phase Oh next generation it's
called a Dustbuster phaser yeah obvious
reasons this version of the phaser gave
way to this version of face oh boy again
this is called a cobra head phaser and
those will fetch about three three grand
each well this one no the the Cobra
heads are a little more common that one
might go for 1,500 to 2,000 dollars
the Dustbuster phaser is pretty rare the
last one sold for about 4045 hundred
dollars so what's this all right so this
is we just got this on a from a
collector in Europe this is actually one
of the scripts however this was used as
a costume guy there are photos damn of
different different characters uh-huh in
costume that were used for continuity
Wow
Alec let's act out a scene okay
captain's log stardate four five zero to
1.3 convincing Starfleet Command to
establish a BOC aid was relatively
painless implementing that plan is
proving more troublesome so anyway
that's what this is so this is a great
that's a great piece what about that
baseball cap what's that is actually
Nog's baseball hat in the episode take
me out to the holosuite in Deep Space
nine oh yeah they played baseball
incredibly large yeah so that's almost
as big as Nick Mundy's caps okay and
then over here these are actually parts
of the enterprise-d model that was used
in the last episode of Star Trek The
Next Generation all good things we saw a
future version of the enterprise which
had three new cells so this and all
these other parts that are here went on
that model oh man so I'm glad you caught
that because I do not have three grand
on me this will probably go for a little
more what are the dates of the auction
the auction happens this Saturday
February 21st Saturday believe it starts
at noon
aha Pacific time and you'll be able to
register we just approve you to be in a
bitter and then you can bid to your
heart's content and the great thing is
there's items from $50 on up to three
thousand three or more people are very
passionate about Star Trek absolutely
find their little niche within Star Trek
that they're very passionate about
collecting that I collect for example
Star Trek phasers on pistols and rifles
and I've got most of most of them I've
been collecting you know for 10 12 years
now can I see one of them sure Alec I
want to thank you for your time and if
you'll excuse me I got some Romulans to
eliminate that was that good Wow
some cool stuff if you could have any
prop from any movie or TV show of all
time what would it be let us know and
tell us why in the comments section
below best answer we're going to send
you a screen junkies t-shirt I want to
thank our guests Alec Peters from prop
works check out his auction online and
thank you for watching I'm how redneck
hit me up on Twitter I like David Spade
laughing is one of my favorite parts of
that sketch like that you can't keep it
here Bryan from what I've heard you're
using your paper not for whitened but
for rolling doobies